on this particular occasion went into
Prince Andrew's bedroom and his
apartments and on his bed was 72 teddy
bears on his bed my inspector showed me
a laminated card which is in the side
side draw
of one of the bedroom cabinets of a
picture of these teddy bears all in situ
and he said the reason for that picture
is that the mice have to put them back
exactly like it's in that picture they
said if they don't he shouts and screams
[Music]
so po can you start with you explaining
to me what actually the job of a royal
Protection Officer means
um basically we provide 24 hours a day
365 days a year arm protection I was
based it back in Palace from 1998 till
2004.
um and my role was to protect the queen
Prince Philip and prince Andrew they
were the ones that lived at Buckingham
Palace at that time
can you give me a bit of an overview
when you joined Buckingham Palace when I
joined I think princess Diner just
passed away the year before
um the unit at the time was sort of uh
um full of Fairly older police officers
coming to the end of their retirement
because it was sort of that kind of unit
back then was a place where you would go
to sort of retire and see the last few
years of your life at in the place
um so from from the impression I got
when I got there
um Prince Charles was not the most
popular of individuals or members of the
royal family because of what happened to
Princess Diana there was a lot of blime
attached to him and and the Royal
household
um so the general feeling amongst
officers was that it was his fault what
happened to princess Diner
what were other members of the Royal
Family Life
they were right um to be fair obviously
uh Prince William Prince Harry when I
was there they were only young they were
really nice kids would always talk to
the place I was whatever and when they
came in and out in the vehicles the
others were pretty much just quite
straightforward Stern didn't really have
any conversation with them the queen
um was very nice I'm better on a number
of occasions in the garden and she would
stop and talk
um obviously you don't talk to her she
talks to you but
yeah she would pass the time of day if
she was in the garden
so you've mentioned that prince Andrew
was one of the people you were about to
protect so what was your first
impression of Princess he was very
um obnoxious uh an angry individual
um obviously we've got a lot of security
procedures at the palace Gates have to
be locked Gates have to be secured
um guests must be vetted before they're
letting
um we never really heard any issues
um with sort of Prince Charles Princess
Anne or Prince Edward because they
weren't resident at Buckingham Palace so
my experience is purely with prince
Andrew and the ways to treat police
officers members of the royal household
the The Waiting staff you know the maids
the footman
um because we were there in direct
contact with him prince Andrew
um would
fly off the handle if we've not opened
the gate for him in time or if we've
stopped one of his guests because we've
not got the right idea or we haven't
been given any information of who they
are it would be verbally abusive
shout swear yeah just really rude
individual how would he treat other
members of stuff
um
the same Maids
um you know the modes come forward and
um explained that once he uh got her to
come up four flights of stairs type in
his curtains when he was sat right next
to him
I remember going in
at the weekend we used to do alarm
checks personal attack alarms in all the
roles bedrooms and private Apartments to
make sure they're working
when they were at Windsor
and on this particular occasion went
into Prince Andrew's bedroom and his
apartments and on his bed was I now know
was 72 I said about 50 but I made
confirm it was 72 kushetta Canton 72
teddy bears on his bed
um and just thinking all right okay and
then my inspector showed me a laminated
card which is in the side
um side draw
one of the bedroom cabinets of a picture
of these teddy bears all in situ and he
said the reason for that picture is that
the mice have to put them back exactly
like it's in that picture they said if
they don't he shouts and screams and
abuses them
and then a mate came came out and
confirmed that she had to do that
otherwise he would shout and scream
so you know that's not not really the
actions of a
a sort of a nice person you know to have
people having to do that
um he's a very
um
self-entitled person I mean more so than
any member of the royal family
um he's stuck out like a saw thumb
no one liked him
talking about prince Andrew and people
visiting him who have you seen visiting
prince Andrew Well the one that I've I
I said publicly about 14 years ago was
gizlo Maxwell
and she was a very frequent guest of
prince Andrew
they're set up with her was most guests
as I say nine to five Buckingham palaces
like a working building so you'll have
guests coming in and out to see members
of the royal family so to set up his at
the front Gates you've got police
officers
and then you've got more police officers
inside the building at the front so the
private secretaries of different members
of the royal family will ring down to
this office called the privy purse and
they will give them all the appointments
for the day for each member of the royal
family so on one particular occasion the
officer in the previous phoned down the
list of appointments for this this day
um
one appointment for prince Andrew we
were told a female guest was attending I
think about one o'clock lunch time but
her name is not to be entered into the
apartments book
that's how we asked why we were told her
name was gizzling Maxwell and then
obviously we realized she was the
daughter of Robert Maxwell
so we we thought yeah obviously it's not
a good look for her to attend the palace
to Queensland if it got out into the
public domain it could be embarrassing
um about an hour later we walked through
a relief from post to walk back to the
Police Lodge and we walked into the
garden the back Garden the Bucking
Palace where the Queen's private
Apartments Overlook and to our right on
the grass by the summer house was a
picnic being set up by a footman and
Maids
um on our way back from the place Lodge
about an hour later prince Andrew was
sitting with gizzling Maxwell having
this particular picnic
and again we said if the queen looks out
the window and realizes that's kissing
Maxwell sat outside on our grass
um she probably wouldn't be too happy
and that was the first time that I um I
encountered her but after that it was
the same routine she was just allowed to
we were told not to not to stop her she
was coming into the palace she was
allowed to just come straight through
security and she would go straight into
the quad where Prince Andrew's private
door is
um she was a regular visitor
and I said this before colleague of mine
noted that she'd come into the palace
and out of the palace four times in one
day
so she was
um headcart Blanche to enter an exit no
one else did no one had that sort of
facility apart from members of the royal
family and to us as police officers uh
seeing this on a daily weekly basis we
form the opinion that there was some
form of relationship going on between
the pair
have you seen any other female guests
coming to Princeton uh yeah I mean as I
mentioned that nine to five is the
office working hours when everyone has
to we have to have their names
that was the only one occasion where we
were not given the name until we asked
for it
um
and um
after five o'clock the palace shuts
there's no more appointments that's
private engagement sort of like guests
of the queen like friends
um and stuff like that who may pop in or
Prince Philip might have a friend coming
in
um
prince Andrew
used to have many frequent female
visitors after 5pm up to 11 p.m at night
the usual form was for us not to ask any
questions we were not given the names of
most of the ladies that were attending
they would have they would turn up at
the front of the palace say they had to
see Prince Andrew
we would ring his his footman and his
personal footman and they would come
down and we would let the females throw
no checks no names and just let them
straight through into the palace to make
the footmen where they would then be
taken up to prince Andrew
obviously she's a clear bridge is
security because we need to know who's
in the palace and we do get people to
turn up saying they're here to see the
queen but they're not they're just
mentally challenged so the idea of
people turning up saying they're here to
see Prince Andrew and we
just letting them in is ridiculous but
if we didn't
I'll give you one occasion when we we
didn't do that a young lady turned up
probably about 22 23 years old
um said she was here to see Prince
Andrew he just came in about half our
previous so we knew he was in
um but the footman wasn't answering his
phone we couldn't there was no way of us
contacting anyone up there so we just
politely said to the lady
um we're really sorry we can't let you
in at the moment because we can't
confirm you're expected
so she said oh should I ring him on my
mobile so we said yeah fine so she rang
prince Andrew on her mobile
um and we could hear him clearly so put
put an officer on the phone so my
colleague took the phone and he said
listen to me you fat ladies
let my guests in immediately I'm going
to come down there everyone heard it the
the lady went red apologized them we
just let her in
so after that obviously those sort of
issues we had with him we would just let
women in didn't ask questions because we
just did not want the grave I mean
complaints are made about him you know
it was a road obnoxious horrible
individual but no one was going to take
a complaint to the Royal household
because he's the Queen's favorite
so we just had to bend the rules for him
and Bridge security
do you think it was quite obvious that
he was quint's favorite yeah
yeah it was definitely the Queen's
favorite
um and probably the reason why he's in
so much trouble now is because he was
the Queen's favorite because no one
reeled him in and he was left to get on
with to do whatever he wanted you know
I'll give you another example
um
we
on the Queen's floor there's cameras
everywhere and we the the camera no it's
an individual in the Queen's private
floor
of our apartments are and we couldn't
identify who it was she wasn't in at the
time but it's still a potential security
alert
so we four of us and I saw four officers
including a sergeant went down to that
Corridor we entered from both ends so we
could obviously meet this person in the
middle
and as we got closer we realized it was
Prince Andrew
so my sergeant explained what happened
apologized I said look we couldn't
identify who it was on campus who had to
come and check it out and instead of
saying Oh I said no problem he said when
he said listen this is my house I'll go
where I want now [ __ ] off
um you know again we're doing our job
there's no need to talk to police
officers like that or anyone like that
you know I've spoken at because people
should know what Prince Andrew's really
like and then judge for themselves I
mean the stuff that I'm saying is being
corroborated by other officers about how
he bullies people how he shouts and
swears you know he's not a nice
individual that's the bottom line
were you sort of surprised when the
Britain case against Bruce Andrew
what I'm saying is look there's two
sides to decline prince Andrew which we
now know and I think a lot of the people
realize his mask is slip now he's not
the clean-cut individual some staunch
royalists thought he was
you know he's obviously um you know he's
gone too far and he said to too many
things he's defended his relationship
with a convicted pedophile
and that to me and a lot of police
officers um you know will we just
couldn't believe it because he's
basically kicked out in the face of
every
um Survivor of sexual offenses around
the world
on the day-to-day basis water possesses
the greatest security risk to the Royals
um
people without mentally challenged
because you you do get a lot of stalkers
with a real family so prince Andrew was
at Windsor in his uh
in his residence in Windsor a female
turns up in a black taxi I think it was
says she's there to see Prince Andrew
she's got she's got an apartment with
him the officers just let her straight
in
and she was mentally challenged she
wasn't a guest and that she was left to
wander around his private house with him
in there somewhere and before they
realized and detained her when she was
arrested so that individual could have
had a knife a gun you don't know and
could have come across prince Andrew
these These are the kind of people on a
date today not so much terrorism
um because we get fret level advice on
briefings every week we will get
security threat assessment basically
from the government that will tell us if
there's any threats to the rules
so with the kind of hierarchy of
protection obviously the queen is at the
at the top of it how many people are
protecting her at the same time
well
say for example at Buckingham Palace
you've got a
um
24 hours a day you've got three or four
shifts and each shift will probably have
about 30 officers on it
so
um and then that that will stay there
all the time even when the queen goes to
Windsor because they'll be they'll be
the same contingent down at Windsor or
if she goes up to Barrymore as I said
half the officers will go with her up to
about mole so she will have quite a
number of places she'll have a corridor
officer as well that's based outside our
bedroom door 24 hours a day 365 days a
year so as soon as she opens her door
there's someone standing there
So within seconds they would be in in
her room if they'd be
from working as a royal Protection
Officer what incident was the greatest
security threat to the Royals
uh we read Fagan who years before I was
ever there who actually got into the
Queen's bedroom and sat on her bed
um and that instigated a lot of it I'm
not going to go through security about
that is to get a lot of security
overhauls within the palace you know
there's there's a lot more
um
cameras beams pressure pads I mean
especially now I've been out I haven't
been there for a long time but I can
imagine the upgrade is quite substantial
the Fagan was the worst I think of all
time apart from when Princess Anne was
some I attempted to kidnap Princess Anne
and I think our protection office was
shot in the mail
um so yeah that was the worst one but
actually getting inside the palace you
it would be very very difficult because
as soon as an alarm goes off you touch
up you touch certain areas alarms will
go off cameras are trained on that
position and then offices will turn out
armed officers from inside the palace
and outside the palace plus helicopters
plus dogs within five minutes the place
is surrounded
so it's it's you know if something ever
did occur it would be shut down
immediately
but during your time there you haven't
witnessed anything no
um let me think
no
no one's going
moving on to other members of the Royal
Family
there's been quite a lot of news going
on about about Harry and Megan and Harry
leaving the royal family but is that
something you could see coming make a
mark Or I think she was 35 or 30 when
she came into the royal family she'd had
a life she was an actress she'd been
married before
um so she was pretty much clued up and I
think what's happened is she's
coming to the royal family and and this
archaic system has tried to control her
and say you will do this you will do
that you will not go here you will not
go there and she's just said no I'm not
going to live like that
um and I think that's what the issue was
because Megan would not conform to the
rules of the royal household and she
wanted to actually have a life
then that's where the problem started
I want to talk a little bit about the
sort of the whole idea of the royal
family generally
as someone who's been around Buckingham
Palace and seen the lifestyle of the
people there I think what's going to
happen is when the queen passes away
then I think the government will look at
um slimming down the royal family
because of the cost implications
potentially you probably get Charles
Camilla William and his wife
as the as the four main Royals with
their children obviously and I think the
rest will their security may all be
slimmed down and so there will never be
a time when it's it's abolished there'll
never be a time that's abolished slim
down yeah
you know like I said to probably four
individuals plus Williams children
um so I mean they already did it with
Harry they cut it cut off his security
um you know because his bill I think
initially when he left he had met
officers living in Canada with him and I
think that that was stopped but his
questions all over the place about who's
paying for what
um but I certainly noticed the security
bill was very very high and they'll be
looking to slim that down once the queen
passes away
[Music]
it's only going to be that obvious up
it's a phone I had a very well known
Hollywood celebrity that was single so
it was very handy to give him one of
these with a pay as you go Sim which
made his life a lot easier if he was
giving out his numbers to new friends